okay now we can have an R session to
demonstrate the bootstrap the
bootstrap's one of the the really
powerful tools we have in modern uh
statistics invented by our friend Brad
Ephron just across the road from us here
and what it does is it lets you get it
the sampling distribution
of statistics for which it's really hard
to develop theoretical versions so the
butcher strap gives us a really easy way
of of of doing statistics when the
theory is very hard and to illustrate it
we'll use the example we used in the in
the book in section 5.2
um we we have a particular particularly
non-linear formula for picking an
optimal combination of two
Investments okay so let's have a look at
that
okay so remember the you had two
Investments
um
X and Y
and let's say they had risk which we'll
call Ver variance of X and variance of Y
this is a guy who cannot distinguish
uppercase and lowercase letters
um and we saw well we told you that the
optimal formula for for getting a
minimum risk investment if you're going
to use Alpha of of x
and 1 minus Alpha of Y is given by the
formula
um
variance of
y
minus covariance
of X and Y
divided by
there we go lowercase a again
Plus
variance of Y
minus 2 times
covariance of X and Y okay so that's a
formula which of course if we have data
on X and Y we can just compute those
variances and covariances and plug them
in and compute our value for Alpha
now that's fine but then you might say
well what is the sampling variability of
alpha what's this what's the standard
error of alpha right how variable is it
going to be well
that's a non-linear formula of X and Y
and you know we just wouldn't know our
priori how to do that
this is a case where the bootstrap
really helps out
so we'll write a function for computing
that formula it's a simple formula given
two vectors X and Y of of actual data
we write our function Alpha
and inside it we compute variance of X
variance of Y covariance of X and Y and
then we just write out that formula okay
and close parents which means that the
the function will return the last line
that was evaluated which is actually our
Alpha okay
and so now we've got a data set
portfolio
which has X and Y in it and we can run
Alpha on the X and Y in that in that
data frame when we do it we see that
Alpha comes up as 0.5758
[Music]
Okay so
in order to to use the bootstrap
function we need to make a little a
little wrapper that that allows the
bootstrap to work and this is this
function we'll call alpha.fn and what it
does is it takes a data frame
and an index which indexes rows of the
data frame and then compute your
statistic in this case you know our
Alpha index for which it wants to
compute the variance in this case the
standard error
now what index does
it's going to be an index into the
numbers 1 to n it'll
have values of 1 to n and there'll be n
of them and there can be repeats of
course because the bootstrap what the
bootstrap does is there's a resample of
your training observations and some
observations can be represented more
than once and some not at all and index
will say which observations get
represented and if they repeated they
you know that'll
that'll be fine because that's what the
bootstrap does
and so what this function does is
just into the function
okay it uses it uses the function width
which is very handy function with says
takes first argument to data frame and
then some commands and it says what it
says is using the data in the data frame
execute the commands so in this case we
use with data of index so that gets the
right observations for this particular
bootstrap sample compute Alpha of X and
Y and the main value of width is that
you can use the named variables X and Y
that are in the data frame okay very
handy
all right let's see if this works we'll
run our function just once using the
original index of the data
portfolio one to n and we see we get the
same value as we got before so that
works and so now we run the bootstrap
and since the bootstrap involves random
uh sampling and if we want to get
reproducible results just for purposes
demonstration it's good to set the
random number seed so there we set seed
one
and now we run
um alpha.fn one more time but we take a
random sample instead of giving an index
1 to n so
here we've sampled the numbers 1 to 100
sample of size 100 with replace equals
two this is the kind of thing the
bootstrap is going to do over and over
here we just do it once okay so we get a
different value of of index that's like
a bootstrap sample of size one
well we'll let the bootstrap do the work
for us and so we call the function boot
we give it the data frame portfolio we
give it our our little function alpha.fn
and we tell it to do a thousand
bootstraps
look how fast that was it's come back
already
if we type boot dot out it gives a
little summary of the bootstrap and it
tells us our original statistic was
0.575 the the estimate
and it gives us the estimate of bias and
standard error we were interested in the
standard error the bias is negligible
it's the standard error in this case is
.08
and that's computed by the bootstrap and
you can also plot the bootstrap it's
nice to see what the distribution looks
like
and you get a two panel plot one is a
histogram and it looks like a pretty
nice symmetric distribution
maybe gaussian and in fact the second
plot is a QQ plot which plots the the
ordered values against the ordered
statistics of a gaussian and if it lines
up on a straight line and I could pretty
much does here you may say it's it looks
close to gaussian maybe a slightly
bigger tail on on the right
so there's the bootstrap very handy way
of getting very good reliable estimates
of standard error for
for nasty statistics